salut c'est le secret aujourd'hui je
vous parlais dans le projet que je
trouve à la fois super cool super
intéressant est à la fois complètement
barré on a le web un pro qui a 3 capteur
photo à l'arrière on pourrait avoir lgv
40 avec cinq capteurs photo et là on
pourra voir le smartphone de la marque
light avec en tout neuf capteur photo
sam pendant que l'homme
c'est une info qui nous vient du
washington post qui a pu voir ce
smartphone le prendre en main qui a
priori le trouve plutôt cool en tout cas
le prototype à ce que le smartphone
n'est toujours pas disponible tout de
suite sans marcher l'idée ce serait un
smartphone avec ont tout neuf capteur
photo situé à l'arrière
ni en rond c'est pas tant d'avoir des
objectifs complètement différents mais
d'avoir un doublon sur certains
objectifs pourra travailler différentes
profondeurs de champ pour pour
travailler
rambur relativement différent alors le
truc son principe me paraît assez cool
c'est à dire on va toujours plus loin au
niveau des photophones on se rend compte
que la photo et la vidéo sont des choses
que les gens utilisent énormément sur
leur consommation de smartphones
maintenant je sais pas si pour vous
c'est le cas pour moi ça les fait
beaucoup de photos que je partage après
sur les réseaux sociaux que ce soit à
titre personnel ou alors sur le sucre
eux enfin je le fais normalement
nordique en vue si vous faites il c'est
le cas et si j'utilise beaucoup de
smartphones pour les photos marquez
bateau sans commentaire en tout cas ce
smartphone permettrait vraiment d'avoir
la solution la plus complète et d'aller
le plus loin possible avec une solution
quasi professionnelle je vous prie de
chats peu le truc vous auriez en fait
neuf caméras neuf caméras qui
permettrait sortir une image globale
fini en 64 millions pixels
quel est l'intérêt aujourd'hui d'avoir
une image sur 104 millions de pixels
pour la photo sur un smartphone et du
partage sur les réseaux sociaux
je suis pas certain que ce soit hyper
pertinents en attendant c'est quand même
une belle prouesse technique ça me
permettrait d'avoir des photos
complètement optimisé en faible
luminosité c'est à dire lorsque vous
allez shooter quelles que soient les
conditions
sortie a toujours une image hyper hyper
et a revu en hausse parce que au final
pour les bras de fer cet appareil c'est
vraiment d'avoir le choix d'avoir le
choix en terme de profondeur de champ
vous avez par exemple photographier ce
n'est pas des gens des personnages avec
une scène derrière vous pouvez avoir
vraiment le focus sur les personnages le
focus sur l'arrière-plan sur un détail à
côté vous avez vraiment choisir le point
vous allez avoir
vous allez voir cinq objectifs de 28 mm
ouverture de f 2.0 et quatre objectifs
de 56 mm une ouverture de f 2.8 chaque
objectif va prendre des photos à une
focale différentes permettra de choisir
après ce que vous voulez avoir dans
l'image cool avoir une aide de flou en
post production
vous avez donc l'appoint technique du
point de vue matériel mais vous la
bosnie wes technique du côté logiciel
c'est à dire vous avez logiciel qui va
assembler tout ça nous permettra une
fois à l'intérieur l'image de faire
votre choix de choisir ce que vous
voulez mettre en oeuvre
de se dire de luminosité oil luminosité
régler la profondeur de champ réduire le
bruit recadrait faire tout ce que vous
voulez pas mal de possibilités
d'ailleurs il faut savoir que la marque
light a déjà sorti l'année dernière
l'année dernière si je dis pas de
bêtises un appareil photo avec 16
capteurs différents à l'arrière sans
être un petit peu une usine à gaz je
vous montre c'est ça la bête 16 capteurs
photo aérienne alors je sais pas si vous
vous rendez bien compte mais qui est
complètement délirant vous avez une bête
de compet pour faire des photos
complètement dingue lippert optimisé
alors néanmoins à nay des choses
qu'aucun reproche à cet appareil photo
déjà le manque de rapidité lorsque vous
voulez chuté ensuite le prix on est
quasiment à 2000 dollars l'appareil
c'est extrêmement cher vous rapprochez
vraiment de prix le boîtier comme le gh5
que j'utilise pour filmer vous là vous
avez un petit appareil compact vous
rajoutez vous avez un vrai reflex
numérique un peu compliqué quand même
cet appareil photo avec ses objectifs
différents un objectif en 28 mm 70 mm et
150 mm le tout pour une image de 50 2
mégapixels on imagine qu'à adapter un
petit peu ce système dans un smartphone
va demander forcément beaucoup de
puissance d'avoir une vraie puissance de
calcul pour pouvoir prendre une photo
optimisé avec neuf capteurs différents
ce smartphone doit être aussi performant
au point de vue matériel au niveau des
optiques au point de vue du processeur
pour l'heure beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de puissance
ware ont cassé tout ça et travailler sur
la photo grande résolution pourra
regarder pour que ça sans manquer c'est
un peu tout ça et aussi du point de vue
logiciel pour pouvoir proposer une
solution qui complètement adapté et
adaptable sur un smartphone
donc on imagine très clairement c'est
quelque chose qui va coûter super cher
j'imagine pas du tout une marque sortira
smartphone à 500 euros
avec cette technologie bien au contraire
on voit que leur appareil photo puis
quasiment 2000 $ alors à mon avis ils
vont pas du tout sortir un smartphone à
2000 dollars par rapport à la
concurrence sur une marque personne ne
connaît du pôle du smartphone un petit
peu compliqué qu'on a vu c'est vraiment
un micromarché c'est vraiment un marché
de niche même si on aime tous avoir de
jolies photos qu'on partage sur les
réseaux sociaux
est ce qu'on est prêt à avoir un
appareil photo hyper optimisé d'une
marque inconnue au bataillon qui même si
derrière vous avez 9 capteur photo est
ce que pour du partage particulier vous
avez besoin
je suis pas convaincu et a contrario les
professionnels sont forcément équipés
avec des appareils photos hyper
performant je suis pas sûr question sur
cette typologie de produits on serait en
rose sur smartphone 2
entre deux destinées au grand public
mais qui va pas forcément être séduit
parce que c'est une solution un peu trop
complexes ou en tout cas pas forcément
trop abordable en termes de coût d'un
côté les professionnels ont déjà des
outils qui leur ont coûté un bras
est-ce qu'ils vont se tourner là dessus
je suis pas convaincu non plus surtout
l'impression d'un mark wright a dépensé
beaucoup d'argent en recherche et
développement pour sortir leurs
appareils photo avec seuls 16 objectifs
différents qui sont pas forcément
rencontré le succès commercial tant
attendu du coup il pourrait cette vie
puisqu'on a une techno qui est éprouvée
qui fonctionne et qu'on a sorti un
appareil photo en utilisant cette
technologie pourquoi on ne pourrait pas
le mettre dans un smartphone ça pourrait
faire un deuxième produit puis peut-être
que ça permettrait à la marque de
rencontrer le succès sur un produit
grand public parce que le produit
technologique que tout le monde avec
soin c'est quand même un smartphone pour
ce que like la vue et comme beaucoup
l'ont vu aujourd'hui la photo fait
partie des points essentiels sur les
smartphones c'est très important de
proposer le smartphone avec une
excellente qualité photo là pour le coup
on ira encore plus loin ont vu venir
huawei avec leur père un pro en disant
ils ont sorti un appareil photo avec 3
capteur à l'arrière
nous on est une techno en promettent
jusqu'à c'est sur un appareil photo si
on en est neuve sur un smartphone avait
quelque chose d'hyper optimiser sa peut
séduire du monde lorsque vous en pensez
en commentaire est ce que ce sens
qu'elle vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter vous sans parler du prix même si
j'imagine que le prix va être quand même
relativement cher est ce que vous
pourriez vous laisser tenter à acheter
un smartphone avec neuf capteur photo
après j'en ai pas du tout en question le
fait que ce soit une bête de compet et
que ce soit super intéressant et vous y
ait vraiment des rendus de qualité qui
soit vraiment magnifique vous puissiez
après à les choisir dans l'image ou est
ce que vous voulez la netteté vraiment
pouvoir optimiser un fonds en arrière
plan dans leurs plans hyper lumineux
pour optimiser une lumière sur une
l'emploi tout ça j'imagine qu'on peut le
faire avec cet appareil néanmoins est ce
que vous seriez prêt vous a posé mille
euros à et en mini 1000 euros sur un
projet comme celui-là je suis pas
convaincu comme je lé 10 un smartphone
qui pourraient être présentées annoncées
fin d'année par light à savoir quatre
applications seraient assurés par
foxconn foxconn sais pas si ce nom vous
dit quelque chose c'est la société qui
assemble les iphone dont qui ont un vrai
savoir faire là dessus voilà pour ce
smartphone avec neuf capteurs photos
dites moi si vous voyez un sens ça peut
vous intéresser si vous seriez prêt à
franchir le pas vous marrer tous ces
commentaires mais cela comme d'habitude
je vous invite à les céder
joli pousse à vous abonner parce que
paraît toujours plus de teck ya plein de
choses plein de produits innovants qui
arrive plein de tests plein nouveau
producteur de nouveautés peu de
surprises donc on reste connectés merci
à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo je
vous dis à très bientôt soyez sages
je vous embrasse ciao
[Musique]